Instantly recognized by most of the
connected world, the Google logo wasn't
always so polished and
also has a rich typographic history.
>> The original logo was
created by Sergey Brin in GIMP
in a typoface called Baskerville Bold.
That's right, in GIMP.
There was even a time when
the Google logo had a exclamation
point like with Yahoo!
>> Ruth Kedar designed
the logo we see today, but
before the final design was reached,
>> She iterated on a whole bunch of
ideas.
The final wordmark is set
in the Catull typeface,
using the primary colors in green.
It's continued to evolve over the past
16 years with minor refinements, and
most recently,
a flatter more simplified look.
>> Now Google doodles have
become a much anticipated
part of the Google.com homepage.
but did you know the idea for
doodles came about when Sergai and
Larry wanted to mark the occasion
of attending Burning Man in 1998.
>> The doodle is a temporary
mask that denotes holidays,
signficant events, or figures.
The doodles stylistically mix
organic and inorganic objects and
figures to make the letter forms.
>> And after viewing just a few of them,
thanks to the gestalt laws of grouping,
your brain immediately
recognizes even very lyrical and
stylized drawings as the individual
letters in the word Google.
>> Now material design utilizes
these very same principles and
concepts to make it easier for
users to comprehend your UI.
Knowing all that will you look at
the Google logo the same ever again?